let's talk about cameras I'm just going
to rush through this because obviously
everyone knows about pinhole cameras
that most basic camera model one can
imagine is basically a box and you make
a super super small hole on the box and
you put a film in it basically some
amount of light will flow into this and
it is going to be caught by the film and
therefore you are going to see an image
on this film we are not that interested
in this model at what you're interested
in is first as a perspective camera
perspective camera means that I have the
lens of the camera this is what you see
the teapot on and this is where the
image is going to be formed and I have a
point somewhere and this is going to be
where the Rays are starting from so I
have to decide and I'm going to shoot
race towards the lens of the camera and
I'm going to be interested in the
continuation of these Ray's what objects
do they hit and what color they are that
is multiple things that I need to
specify when creating a perspective
camera this plan can have the width the
height some kind of field of view and
the aspect ratio is given by the ratio
of the width and the height what about
the field of view well if you would like
to play first-person shooters you have
probably fiddled with settings like that
but the field of view is basically what
you see here and different camera models
or different eye models have different
fields of view so for instance it's
quite different for a course if you
would like to model how her see
something and the field of view will be
much larger because the eyes are on the
sides so you can always see what it was
behind it and we have a given field of
view that we can model here and this can
be arbitrarily changed if you have a
good perspective camera implementation
let's quickly put together an
implementation of that
what I'm interested in is that I'm going
to give an XY pair these are pixel
positions
give me the zero pixel in terms of X and
v pixel of with respect to Y and this is
going to give me back a world space
coordinate where this is exactly on the
lens
so I'm subdividing this lens into pixels
I only want to care about the pixels
because each pixel after each other they
are going to be computed how much light
is going through these pixels and
therefore these world space coordinates
are interesting so if I instantiate such
a perspective camera the height and the
width is definitely given and the field
of view with respect to the x axis is
also given and the desired pixel
positions are going to be XP and YP well
what are these variables are supported
on some XP and YP are on 0 and W and H
so these are really the pixels which
pixel am i interested in the field of
view can be like reasonably arbitrary
but same choices on 0 PI and the field
of view with respect to the y direction
can be computed from the aspect ratio
and the other field of view this is the
end result and before we try to
understand what's going on let's try to
play with it and this I do because
usually if you read literature math
books whatever you'll never see the
journey be having things you get the
answer and this is usually a huge
formula that doesn't seem to make any
sense so let's get a bit more
experienced on how to play these
formulae how can we understand so for
instance let's forget a in X&Y let's
forget this tangent terms and let's just
play with the fraction so I substitute X
and y equals 0 XP and y equals 0 so what
do I have for the x coordinate well it's
2 times 0 minus 2 with over over the web
therefore this is minus
one and I have the same provide so this
is you know minus H over H that's minus
one so for the zero zero pixels
I have workspace positions of minus 1
and minus 1 therefore this is going to
be the bottom left so so far this seems
to make some sense what if I stopped it
to the other end for the pixels well if
I have W for XP then I have to W minus W
/ W and therefore this is going to be
one both for X and both forward so this
is going to be the upper right and
whenever I specify it for XP and YP
between these two extreme values
then this is really going to give me the
world space coordinates of this camera
body we have forgotten about the
tangents but let's put them back I don't
know what I just did now but it's
working again I wonder why this
presenter has like two million five
hundred buttons pair okay
let's not digress so I multiply back
these numbers with these tangents and
then I can see that basically whether it
gives me more perspective distortion so
the higher the field of view with
respect to axis the more perspective
distortion I'm going to get well this is
already a good enough description that I
can put in code in fact I have already
coded it up and this is a very simple
function that that's exactly what we
have been talking about it's simple as
that so if you don't take the prototype
of the function this is basically fine
lines and this is still readable so this
could be even less so not too shabby I
mean a perspective camera in five lines
of code passed there are also other
graphic cameras this is a large
difference between from the perspective
camera because the rays of light are
also parallel with each other and they
are perpendicular
to this camera plate so basically they
don't start from one point looking
outwards they are perfectly parallel
with each other and perpendicular to
this lens and they also don't meet at
the eye and you can see that the
perspective distortion is completely
omitted here so you can see here the
same image the same scene with the same
settings with a larger graphic and the
perspective camera and you can see that
the realism is completely different in
the two there's another example with Lux
Ronda in the next image you won't see
the environment map in the background
that disregard that because the
implementation of environment maps with
orthographic cameras is in a way
non-trivial so lots of perspective
distortion well maybe you don't notice
because this is what you're used to but
if you have an orthographic camera then
it is a perfect distortion free
geometric shape and back to the
perspective camera so this fourth gives
you a significant perspective distortion